[music playing]
So the terrain here
is definitely getting
steeper and more committing.
But you know, so
much of survival
is about just trying
to be resourceful.
I just wonder if maybe we
maybe use that old trunk.
Use that, get that down, and
then we can down climb that.
Let's have a look at it, anyway.
Yeah.
[laughs] Is there some
way we can use our ax
to make the ladder out of that?
Yeah, brilliant idea.
Brilliant.
[laughs]
BEAR GRYLLS: Totally.
Maybe if we, like, cut
little steps into it--
it doesn't have to be
big, you know, just enough
to use as hands and feet.
Drag it, drop it down.
Maybe tie this rope to the end
of it so it stays in place.
Sure.
We passed this old
log on the way down.
Have you got that ax on you?
Yeah.
Let's bring the ax up here.
And of course, because the
air is so dry out here,
nothing really rots.
Rock hard, though, this wood.
But whatever it was
used for one time,
we're going to use it
for our purpose, which
is getting down this crack.
So if you could give us the
ax, what we're trying to do
is trying to get--
We can cut some
little steps into it,
and drop it down this crack,
and use those, and down climb.
[chopping]
[music playing]
Let's get you doing
a bit of that.
I'm going to get this rope
ready, and then we're into it.
DAVE BAUTISTA: Bear's
plan is to somehow
climb down this log
ladder that we've built
from our two hands and an ax.
[laughs]
BEAR GRYLLS: OK.
So that's a bunch of steps cut.
And now, what we've got
to do is position it.
So if you take the heavy end--
All right.
I'll this end.
You read?
Heading that way?
We're going down to the right.
Yeah.
DAVE BAUTISTA: Yep.
BEAR GRYLLS: Oh, my god.
[laughs] Bautista,
you crack me up.
Here we go, right?
It's literally like
he's moving a matchstick.
This is so heavy.
Well, the great thing
about having Dave Bautista
on this journey is
that when you're
moving heavy tree trunks
around, it suddenly all
becomes a little bit easier.
OK, watch your step down there.
We'll let gravity do the
work now, if you put it down.
And then we'll come up this end.
DAVE BAUTISTA: I
feel OK climbing
down this log right now.
But as Mike Tyson
said, everybody
always has a plan until they
get punched in the face.
So I'll see--
[laughs]
--how it starts looking when
we're actually doing this.
But as of right now,
I'm extremely confident.
[laughs]
So when I go down, am
I going down, like,
keeping my weight on the rope?
Or should I try
to balance myself?
A bit of both.
- A bit of both.
- A bit of both, yeah.
As you get steeper,
it's going to be
more natural to use
your hands and stuff
and your feet as well.
So--
DAVE BAUTISTA: OK.
OK.
[suspenseful music]
OK, tell me when
you're at the top.
Not yet.
Almost.
OK, I got my foot on it.
OK, now try and use the
log because I'm going to--
I'm struggling to hold
you on that one side.
OK.
[grunts]
BEAR GRYLLS: Keep talking to me.
Are you on there?
I can't see you now.
Yeah, I'm on the log.
And these notches are much
farther apart than I thought.
[laughs]
OK, I'm down.
I made it.
OK, good job.
OK, I'm going to follow
you down this line.
That were a pretty
good one there.
DAVE BAUTISTA: Yeah.
[laughs]
Yeah, look at that.
DAVE BAUTISTA: [laughs]
Good job.
Well done.
When I got a little high,
it was a little scary.
And there was a
couple times where
I just wanted to wrap
myself around the log
and hopefully slide down.